مساء الخير الدول التي تملك المال تملك
النفوذ والتاثير على دول العالم الاخرى
وهي تمارس هذا النفوذ من خلال ما يعرف
صناديق الثروه السياديه وهو دا موضوع
حلقتنا النهار ده لكن عشان نفهم يعني اه
صندوق ثروه سياده من المهم اساسا نحنا
نعرف يعني استثمار في المطلق بالاساس اي
صندوق استثمار هو عباره عن شركه بتدير ام
والمستثمرين مختلفين افراد وشركات وهيئات
بهدف تحقيق اكبر عائد ممكن واقل قدر ممكن
من المخاطر صندوق الاستثمار السيادي هو
ايضا صندوق استثمار يعني يخضع لنفسه فكره
صندوق الاستثمار العادي جدا ولكنه لا يوجد
كلام والافراد ولا شركات وانما يدير اموال
دول وحكومات هل معنى كده انه كل دوله
عندها صندوق سيادي الاجابه قطع الصندوق
السيادي ينشا حين يقول للدوله فائض من
الاموال يعني ان فائض من الاموال كل دوله
عندها معاملات مع العالم الخارجي اشتري
منه فاذا كان مثلا اجمالي باتت بيعه من
سلعه اكثر من اه اجمالي ما تستورده انساني
اللي هي عندها فائض في معاملاتها مع
العالم الخارجي ما ينطبق على السلع ينطبق
على الخدمات ينطبق على الاستثمارات او
رؤوس الاموال مثال للسل علشان تتخيل
الخدمات علشان تتخيل معي الوضع انت ممكن
تصدر السياحه لما عده تستقبل عدد كبير جدا
من السائحين في اسبانيا مثلا زي دبي انت
استقبلت اخذت فلوس الناس مقابله انتقدت هم
خدمه السياحه على ارضك وبالتالي انت حصلت
على اموال اذا كان ان ت تستقبل اموال من
السياحه اكثر من الاموال اللي تنفقها
مواطنين في العالم الخارجي يبقي انت كده
دوله دائمه دوله يتفاعل دوله تتمتع بفائض
نتيجه ان اجمالي معاملاتها من سلع وخدمات
ورؤوس اموال اكبر مما تدفع تحصل على من
العالم اكثر مما تدفع لذلك العالم اذا كان
الفائده بيروح فين عددنا الفائده يروح الى
ما يعرف الاحتياطي النقدي اللي يشرف عليه
البنك المركزي ذكر الاحتياطي النقدي محدود
الاحتياطي النقدي محدود كما هو مثلا في
حاله الدوله في مصر او في تونس هي ب تكتفي
بانهم تجنبه
بحيث انه يكون احتياطي ليها
لاستيراد الضرورات لها لعده شهور في حاله
وجود اي طوارئ وب تستثمر في ادوات يمكن
تسهيلها بسهوله فى ادوات الدين مثلا
الامريكيه اشترى ديون امريكا ودي ادوات
يمكن تسهيلها والحصول على الاموال الشراء
احتياجاتها من القمح او الذره او العلاج
في حاله الطوارئ اما اذا كانت دوله عندها
في ضخمه جدا في الكويت الامارات السعوديه
او زي النوويه في الحاله هي تستثمر هذه
الفائت الضخمه من خلال صندوق فهو سياسي او
الصفر المولد
السنه دي بتحقق منفعه ضروريه اه يعني اه
ضرر المنفعل الاساس هي ان هي بتعمل تنويع
لاستثمارات هذا البلد يعني مثلا اي بلد
الامارات مثلا او السعوديه تسعين في
المائه من ع وانها بيجي نتيجه بيع النفط
والغاز
وبالتالي اذا انخفضت اسعار النفط والغاز
الموازنات العامه في هذه الدول ب تعالى
صندوق استثمار على مدار سنه والطويله
بيكون
اي اضطرابات في يلبسون المنفعه يديها فرصه
التنويع استثماراتها في اسواق مختلفه
كثيره وفي قطاعات المختلفه الضرر انه اذا
كان في فريق الضخم
ان استثمر وتم ضخمه في صوره مثلا رواتب
للمواطنين يكون فيه نسبه سيوله ضخمه في
سوق هذا البلد وبالتالي يكون فيه تضخم
ارتفاع الاسعار فتكون اضراره اكثر من
فوائده
او من صندوق سيادي في العالم كان سنه الف
تسعمائه ثلاثه وخمسين وكانت دوله الكويت
هي صاحبه او الصندوق السيادي بهذا المعنى
في العالم ثم تبعها عدد كبير من الصديق
المختلفه احنا عندنا حوالي بس انتو
باستثمار في العالم في معك اسم معهد
الصناديق السياديه او اه
والفرنسي استفيد والمعهد معهد متخصص
لدراسه كل حركات واه استثمارات الصناديق
السياديه في العالم بس بالمعهد ه مقر
وامريكا عاده هو بيشتغل على حوالي ثمانيه
وسبعين تسعه وسبعين صندوق مؤخرا وصل
بالعدد اللي ميه لما بعض الدول الفقيره
عملت شي استثمار باستهزاء الدول الفائده
على سنه استثماريه قصه ثانيه مش موضوع
النهار ده سبعين ثمانين صندوق استثمار دول
اجمالي ما يحكوا من الوصول هي حوالي اخر
تقدير الى هذا المعهد في اكتوبر 2013 كان
اجمالي اصول الصناديق السياديه في العالم
ثمانيه كلينتون ترليون دولار يعني تسهيل
بيقول ثمانيه مليون دولار
ترليون دولار زي ما حضرتكم عارفين يعني
الف مليار دولار
ضخمه جدا جدا ايه هي اكبر الصناديق
السياديه في العالم
طبعا تقيم الصندوق ترتفع وتنخفض لانه
الصناديق تستثمر في يعني تستثمر في اسهم
شركات ابتسمت ستسهم في سندات شركات الدول
واحيانا تستثمر استثمار مباشر يعني تشتري
عبارات او تشتري شركات او نصيب كبير من
شركه وبالتالي بيكون استثمار مباشر في
مصنع وفي شركه او في مؤسسه اعلاميه لاخر
ولانه هذه الاصول
كانت اسهم او سندات او يعني اصول
استثمارات مباشره ترتفع وتنخفض
قيمه ما تملكه هذه الصناديق بترتفع وقت
الخفض لكن بتظل تقريبا الصادق الكبيره هي
تحتفظ بمركزها
مع اختلافات طفيفه على مدار سنوات طويله
يعني على مدار سنه والطويله صندوق اكبر
صندوق استثمار في العالم بلا منازع هو ست
دول الاستثمارات النرويجيين هذا الصندوق
وكان اول شركه تتخطى وصولها حاجز بليون
دولار في التاريخ والكلام ده كان في
سبتمبر 2017 ثم عندنا مجموعه ايضا من
صناديق الاستثمار فهنا في المنطقه
طبعا السعوديه والامارات والكويت وقطر الى
اخره ايهم الترتيب اخر ترتيب اه وفقا
صناديق الثروه السياديه في العالم الترتيب
على النحو التالي احنا عندنا صندوق الثروه
ال النرويجي تسعمائه وتسعين
مليار دولار يعني مثل شويه عندنا صندوق
الاستثمار الصيني اللي هو شان انفسنا
وده كان وتسعمائه اثنين واربعين مليار
دولار عندنا بعدين جهاز ابوظبي للاستثمار
كنتم حوالي سته سبعه وتسعين مليار دولار
عندنا الثروه الكويتي
خمسمائه
اسفها خمسه اثنين وتسعين مليار دولار
عندنا بعد كده كونغ 509 مليار دولار عندنا
صندوق صيني اخر باسم سيف
واربعمائه واربعين مليار دولار ثم رئيسي
الدور اللي سنغافوره كنت وتسعمائه وتسعين
مليار دولار عندنا
وهو ايضا تابع الى سنغافوره
وكانت تسميه خمسه وسبعين مليار دولار
عندنا صندوق ثالث للصين اسمه ناشرا
الكونغرس اذا كنت ميه واحد واربعين مليار
دولار ثم عندنا في المركز العاشر صندوق
الثروه القطري وكانت و 320 مليار دولار
الفين السعوديه السعوديه دائما بتحط ب احد
المراكز المتقدمه في اول عشر مراكز وعندها
اخر دائما بينافس على احد اكبر السنين في
العشرين واستند واين دولهم قبل
كانت اسم انتوا الاستثمارات العامه في
المتوسط حوالي ميه وستين مليار دولار
عندنا 75 115 مليار دولار لكن المعهد اللي
عنده عاده لما يحصل تغيير اول ما بتوصل مش
بيانات محدثه فهو لا يذكرها وبقي كده انه
المطلوب انه او مجال تحديث الرقم في كل
الاحوال الارقام بتتغير لكن هذه الصناديق
هي ب تحتل صداره الصناديق في العالم
ملحوظه لو اذا نقرا القائمه نلاحظ عده
ملاحظات او لا اكثر من نصف الثمانيه مليون
دولار هي لدول تملك نفط وغاز بالدرجه
الاولى وباقي ال 48 يعني الاربعه الاخرى
هي عندها فائض نتيجه قوه اقتصاد ضخمه جدا
في الصين
سنغافوره هل لاحظ ان اجمالي صناديق الثروه
الاهمال الاصول والصناديق السنه الصينيه ب
يتعاظم شك
يتوافق او بيعبر عن صعود الصين الضخم جدا
يعني مثلا لما نجي نشوف في قائمه العشر
دول اللي احنا احنا ذكرنا الثلاث صناديق
ثروه سياديه تابعه للصين لما نجمع الارقام
اللي هم الثلاثه البعض بيعطوا الواحد
وسبعه من عشره مليون دولار وترقب ضخمه جدا
يعني يعني لك ان تتخيل عشان تعرف حجم
التضخم المالي الجيد في العالم كل وفقا
لاخر تقدير اربع وثمانين مليونا ر تقريبا
اجمالي ما ينتجوا العالم كله الماليه نشوف
انه صندوق الصندوق النرويجي
الاصول بحوالي ترليون يعني بيملك حوالي
واحد واثنين من عشره من اجمالي كل ما
ينتبه العالم من سلع وخدمات خلال عام كامل
الصين من خلال الثلاث السنه دول بتملك
طبعا اكثر من هذا الرقم ب تملكه بحوالي
مثلا اثنين في المائه
يعني من اجمالي كل ما ينتبه العالم من سلع
وخدمات في عام كامل لو لاحظنا انه بلد
الامارات نشيطه جدا في صناديق الاستثمار
لانه عندها اكثر من صندوق يعني عندها
عندها جهاز ابو ظبي عندها مجلس ابو ظبي
عندها هيئه الامارات للاستثمارات حتى لو
كان معانا الثلاثه او الاربعه اجمالي هذه
الصناديق المختلفه هذا تجاوزا ترليون
ومائتين مليار دولار ونفس الامر بالنسبه
لدول اخرى عندها اكثر من صندوق استثمار
هذه الصناديق بدات على استحياء في
الخمسينات ثم الستينات ثم بدات مؤخرا ب
تستثمر بشراسه ضخمه جدا سواء في الاسواق
الناميه في افريقيا تستثمر في موانع فيه
طرق في اه بناء مصانع بناء مطارات تستثمر
ايضا في شرائع الضخم جدا من الاصول في
الدول الغنيه وكانت هذه الصناديق عمله
اخرى ضخمه جدا بعد الازمه الماليه
العالميه في 2008 لما العالم كاد ان تنهار
السوق وال متقدمه زي الولايات المتحده ورب
هذه الصناديق دخلت وانقذت مؤسسات ضخمه في
سيدي بنك مثلا مؤسسات كانت على وشك
الانهيار لما هي اشتريتها اخذتها من
الانهار وبالتالي ابقت على
المنطقه وعلى يعني استثمارات هذه الدول
المتقدمه لانها
هذه الدول ووضعت يدها على اصول مهمه جدا
فالعالم الغربي ممكن ي اليها ولكنه يشعر
بالقلق من تصاعد انفسهم ولانها تستثمر
بشراسه في الاسواق المائه سواء في اسيا او
في افريقيا وفي امريكا اللاتينيه
الشعوب والحكومات ممتنه اليها ولكنها بدات
تخاف تدريجيا من نفوذها المتصاعد واحنا
تكلمنا الاسبوع اللي فات على
حلقه او من يومين ثلاثه على حلقه سريلانكا
وازاي انه سابق الثروه السياديه الصينيه
تستثمر بشراسه في سلال انت فاذا عقدت
سيريلانكا على السداد تضع هذه الصناديق او
الصين ايديها على هذه الاستثمارات علينا
ان نتابع في الفتره القادمه تحركات صناديق
الثروه السياديه احيانا في الصحف والجرائد
انا ما بيقولو ش كلمه صندوق سيادي
السعوديه او ابو ظبي مثلا اشترت المؤسسه
الفلانيه اشتريت ثلاثين في المائه من
الشركه الفلانيه تشترك كذا من هي ال
الدوله ما بتشتري عن طريق وزاره الخارجيه
هي بتشتري عن صناديق الثروه السياديه اللي
احنا يجب ان نتبعها باهتمام اذا اردنا ان
نفهم ما يجري على الساحه الاستثماريه
والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
اشكركم على لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]